while a pandemic swept through our world
and infected tens of millions
last night it was the nba suspending its
season after rudy gobert of the utah
jazz tested positive for the coronavirus
the league will use this hiatus to
determine the next steps
in dealing with the pandemic i play for
the fans that's what it's all about so
if i show up to a reading ain't no fans
in there i ain't playing
so they do what they want to do we all
talk shortly after we shut down the
season
and of course we've always been looking
for
um whether or not there is an
appropriate
and safe way in which we can resume
basketball avery bradley has decided not
to enter
the bubble trevor ariza opted out of the
uh of the bubble
maverick center willie cauley stein
saying he's decided to sit out the
resumed nba season
another crisis with roots hundreds of
years long
and tied to our country's history
brought americans to the streets
demanding change police killing george
floyd had to mark a turning point
police shootings and police killing of
african-americans like myself
like this isn't new it's just everyone
has iphones now
so it's getting recorded it has been a
painful night of violence and protests
in minneapolis it is your duty not to
burn your own house down for anger with
an enemy
brianna taylor a 26 year old emt was
shot eight times by police
who was listening to the black community
that are in the streets that are out
here that haven't made it to this level
that are experiencing that they're
getting pulled over just discrimination
day after day dealing with the same the
same [ __ ]
and this this is this is systematic
while the coronavirus reared its head
so did the realities of systemic racism
long felt by black people in america and
too long ignored by so many others
to see all you guys come together for
one cause for justice
for peace i'm just happy man and
i challenge all you guys to continue to
stick together
[Music]
what do we want
meanwhile basketball moved into a bubble
getting ready to take off to orlando
check into this bubble would this bubble
be a success
the country asked for sports to bring
healing i chose black lives matter
because
black lives matter black lives matter on
buses
on the court on jerseys a lot of people
kind of use this analogy to talk about
black lives matter as a movement not a
it's not a movement
when you black it's not a movement it's
a lifestyle the league promised to say
their names
to say her name justice for brianna i
want her family to know and i want the
state of kentucky to know
that we feel forward and we want justice
i have pretty much
every possible name or someone's died
from police brutality
[Music]
but the change that is necessary many
wondered if its momentum would be lost
inside the walls of a new arena
when players said there was not enough
changing basketball stopped
breaking news now nbaa television has
just announced that the milwaukee bucks
are boycotting the nba playoff game that
is scheduled to happen right now our
focus today cannot be on basketball
we are calling for justice for jacob
blake and demand the officer be held
accountable
you know you should watch uh watch a guy
get shot
you know in front of his entire family
and then right
underneath that video is somebody saying
hey well he should have just listened to
the police so like
like you you take all that whether you
register it or not whether you realize
what you're looking at or not like
you're taking that in and that
appreciation of life and you know kind
of
get numb to what you're looking at and
you almost start to
question yourself as a black man as a
former player
i think it's for best for me to support
the players
and just not be here tonight they
demanded change
we're not trying to defund the police
and take all their money away
we're trying to get them to protect us
just like they protect everybody else
the job isn't done yet
and we can't stop until black lives
really do matter
they sought justice they urged us to
vote
hopefully the initiatives that we came
together that we partnered with
voting sites and the arenas and things
of that nature hopefully
years on down the down the line america
is in a better place
that you can look back to this moment
and be like that was one of the
kind of faults that kind of gotta go i'm
proud to announce that we have
over 90 of our league registered to vote
15 teams are 100
registered and the job that guys have
been doing
just to be a little bit more educated on
the situations and getting people out
recruiting poll workers and things like
that
the bubble has been an unbelievable
blessing
our players are continuing to do the
work and we're grateful and we're going
to keep working
can we call this bubble a success i
think
the biggest thing was us being able to
come together as a group and try to
figure out ways to continue to impact
society
i think we've continued to do that and
hopefully we continue to to uplift
and put light on some of the injustices
that we're seeing in america
came down here for a reason and
obviously to win a championship but to
spread the message
stop playing and continue playing
because i'm going to continue to preach
our messages not just for the game but
i'm very happy with the way things went
as far as being able to connect
as these playoffs go as everybody
watches we continue to push
what's really needed in this world um
it was challenging it was
well put together um the teams and the
players
the development drive sacrificing we
used our um
a platform for our voices to be heard
and then the social
justices you guys are out there to vote
uh
you know just brian taylor um you know
just
for everybody you know every black
american out there
that are being harmed by police and he's
brutality
there are still questions but we are
listening
my skin color should not determine
whether i live or die
um this is a human civil rights crisis
that's going on
the game was great we won by two by the
end of the day brad brianna taylor's
killer is still free
there's so many different things that we
can honestly talk about i'm going to
continue to talk about brianna taylor
uh that's near and dear to me one thing
for me is that you know brianna taylor
killers still still uh roam around freak
so i think
i just want to focus on that with these
interviews and things like that so i
just want to keep the focus there
we want to make sure that daniel cameron
will arrest the cops
and officers involved with brianna
taylor's
death my answer is going to be justice
for
briana turley's my for everything so
i'm just letting you guys know that now
that's good
that's gonna be my answer for every
question fair enough
for daniel cameron to step up and to do
what's right
and that's the only message i got today
i appreciate everybody
thanks thanks steve where did we go from
here we don't we don't stop
obviously you know when the season ends
you know in less than a week
that everyone disperses and goes back
but i hope that people continue to
use their platform use their individual
social media platforms
they're doing it that way you're
welcome individually your community does
it that way
however however that you continue to
create change
for the better of all of us i think it's
a
it only makes us all better
[Music]
[Applause]